[Music]
joining me today is the author of the
art of the argument Western
civilization's last stand and the host
of freedomain radio stefan molyneux
welcome to the Rubin report thank you
great pleasure to be here in a while it
has been a while I've been on your show
a couple times before we get into
anything of real substance though I do
feel we have to address the amount of
grey that we both have in our beards
because it what's with the chin area
that I don't know I mean the first time
I had a beard and it went gray I've been
outside in Canada in the winter and I
was like oh it's just a little bit of
you know a little snow little ice or
something like that it's like just brush
away the father time doing his work I
have never had a beard in my life this
is my first beard ever so I didn't even
know that gray was there now I feel old
and tired and here's the thing too once
you have the beard in public view you
can't dock in it you know you can't
because it's too late like soon as you
like even if you get a bit of stubble
because you know there's people who
obsess about everyone's looks on the
internet you get a little bit of stubble
you can't yeah yeah you can't shoe
polish it up you can't do that you know
you just you got to let it go
what number are you buzzing with I'm
sort of like a number two kind of thing
I'm like an 8 ah okay we'll see yeah I
went into the controversial stuff well
now here's the thing because by now
you're okay because you have fairly
lengthy hair yeah but I cannot be the
guy with a beard much longer than his
hair that's a whole like Montana living
in the caves kind of look that has you
like everyone thinks that you're cooking
beans on a fire in an old shoe waiting
for the end of civilization there's got
to be a youtube series about that I'm
sure but yeah so I've got to keep it
fairly trim no matter which way yeah all
right well we have a lot to get to and I
really want to talk about the book but I
thought the best way to sort of start
this is that I know I'm gonna get a
certain amount of heat just for sitting
across from you and as I said I've been
on your show a couple of times before
and we've had nothing but pleasant
conversations have talked about
liberalism and logic and reason and all
that stuff but I think you're you're
somewhat aware of that type of thing
that for some people you are you may get
negative opinions about a free thinker
on the Internet I think actually
pre-internet it was Socrates and then
you know Copernicus not to put myself in
such lofty categories but there
certainly is when you are enriched
thinker and when you really try and
particularly when you scrub things down
to the bare minimum like car Randy
Descartes said like what if I know
nothing whatsoever what if I just wipe
everything out and try and build a
coherent and rational framework of
thinking and of understanding the world
and of understanding ethics what if I
just pretend I know nothing which is a
Socratic a moment you know nothing what
are you going to build from scratch and
I think that's the modern world is when
people said we don't know anything we
don't know whether the Sun or the the
earth is the center of the solar system
we don't know anything let's just
pretend we know nothing we don't even
know if the king is put there by God we
don't know if the aristocracy
is put there by God we don't know if the
priests are right about everything what
if we just wipe the slate clean and then
we build things up and we get modern
civilization I think out of that but
there are a lot of entrenched interests
that profit from existing error and when
people come along with better arguments
well it can be a little controversial
toss in a certain dose of Twitter and
then yeah you know you get where we are
now it's funny because I've had a little
bit of a change over the last couple of
months where I was kind of really just
you know everybody talks about well
we've never been more divided we're all
angry at each other we all hate each
other I think there's actually a great
opportunity right now for people that
are talking about ideas and I include
you in that but what would you say is
the thing that people find most
controversial about you is there one
time that you consistently hit on that
you think people either give you the
most flak or you think is sort of
waiting into the most inflammatory if I
knew that day if I would hit on it more
I've got a couple right here but I
thought I'd throw that to you you think
I would say I would say that the concept
so there's some abstract ones unless
impersonal ones no and people tend to
get most upset about the person once
because that's where people have kind of
like a stake in in their life in their
world so for me for sure I think people
get most upset when I talk about say for
instance you don't have to have abusive
people in your life you know whether
they're that's what the one is that's
number two one above that but we can
start with that sure so you know when I
was growing up I don't know for some of
you listen if they may hear Paleozoic
maybe something
but when I was growing up this was
everywhere when I was a kid and this was
part of the feminist revolution right
where they said if you are with an
abusive man you should get out you
should you know hit the road jack don't
look back deep in the rearview nothing
but dust right and that was something
that I grew up if you're being abused if
you're in an abusive relationship then
you should not be in that relationship
now I actually think that's a little too
harsh I think you should sit down and
talk with people and try and reason
things out and so on but that seems
relatively uncontroversial when you're
talking about adults but I think one of
the things that people got upset about
is when I logically at least to me
extended that to if you're an adult and
you had an abusive parent do you
actually need to continue to spend time
with that abusive parent and the answer
to me is well no because if you marry
someone that's a Chosen relationship
right I mean but your parent is someone
like I'm a parent right and I recognize
that my daughter did not choose me she
liked eenie meenie there's no there
wasn't like some you know this platonic
idea that you're kind of floating above
the world you look down and you pop some
cosmic game yeah I don't know about no I
don't really I mean so she didn't choose
me so it's an involuntary relationship
for for children and to me you have to
have the very highest standards when you
have the least voluntary relationship
and so when I put that argument forward
well some people seem to get quite upset
and yes it has always been you know from
a logical standpoint it's completely
baffling from a sort of personal
standpoint I can understand why so on
the logical front it makes sense because
you would just remove bad influences
from your life whether they're part of
your family or not your family it's just
that that I think well I think talk to
them first yeah I mean you don't show
that's what I want you know how far do
you think you have to go before you
would cut out something like a parent I
know it's I mean I I have this sort of
rule I don't tell people what to do in
the show because I mean not only would
that be kind of megalomaniacal but also
let's say somebody just Abbes you then
learned anything right so I wouldn't so
to say to people want but I would say
that it's hard to have a better
relationship in your life than your
worst relationship and so if you have a
very dysfunctional relationship and
there are certainly you know people out
there whose
parents were unfathomably evil towards
them you know like a mana station rape
of violent abuse you know massive
neglect and so on right so I think try
and talk to people in your life but do
not think that it's like physics that
you just have to have relationships
because I'm very big for freewill very
big for choices and I always have a kind
of reflexive pushback against you have
to you know
well it's your father's birthday you
have to call him it's like well he beat
me up every day of our childhood do I
really I do i maybe I'll skip this one
the kiss because people don't say well
you chose this man you have to stay
married to him even if he's drunkenly
beating you every night people said no I
mean and and again that's a chosen
relationship so involuntary
relationships I think there's a higher
standard so I think it's important you
sit down you talk about if you've had a
difficult history with your family your
parents sit down and talk about it with
them and you know if they want to go to
therapy if they want to try and find
ways to resolve it so much the better
what can be repaired should be repaired
but that's not up to you in the end Road
in the end is part of the conflict there
that so many of us walk around not
really dealing with issues in the first
place so I remember once years ago about
ten years ago a good friend of mine was
telling me about his relationship with
his dad he said his dad was abusive and
was always drunk and that one night he
came home his dad came home drunk and
basically just beat the living hell out
of him and that he has a 12 year-old
knew at that moment this guy is just you
know a dirtbag and I'm gonna always
treat him as such and in a bizarre way
he had very clean feelings about it as
the act of being punched and beaten was
so clean yeah but I think a lot of
people if you don't get hit there's all
sorts of other abuse so you walk around
in this sort of half truth phase you
know I can't quite parse it out do you
think that's part of it that people
don't quite yeah people have good
memories yeah you know that there's very
few people in the world that's like well
that person was evil from dawn until
dusk they woke up they were evil and
there was never I mean people always
have good memories even of bad people in
their life and so it definitely is
complicated and if you can use the good
memories as a way of hooking the
relationship to a better place fantastic
but we were talking just a little bit
before about you
sort of Weinstein scandal and all this
kind of stuff and just while we were
talking that the thought popped into my
mind Dave that we look at Hollywood and
we say oh you know these people they
seem to know or there's lots of
indications or lots of jokes or lots of
stuff where people said oh we knew we
knew and then people why didn't they say
something why didn't they say something
it's like well you can think that the
only problem with that is somewhere out
in Hollywood somewhere out among the
rich famous pretty people who have
massive talent more money and it seems
like decreasing levels of ethics as
every day goes forward but what about
people in your own life do you know for
instance not you personally but do you
audience do you do you in the audience
know somebody who's mistreating a child
do you know a parent who is and this can
be neglect and it likely is a very very
powerful form of abuse that is very hard
to unpack in in your mind do you have
suspicions you know do you see parents
you know screaming at their children or
spending their whole time on the cell
phone and not talking to them and so on
is there something that you can do to
improve that to remind them and say you
know your kids are only young ones try
and engage them in a positive way teach
them how to be rational by being
rational to them and love them and be
positive to them because it's not just
out there in Hollywood where there's all
this bad stuff that people aren't doing
people most people if you have any kind
of extended social circle extended
family and so on most people have
something in their life that they could
stand up for and say this needs to be
better this should be improved yeah and
I think that's one of the fascinations
that's going on but this Hollywood
scandal is people are saying they do say
well what about all the people who knew
but didn't do anything but I think most
of us and I can't myself in this as well
and play out in my life I've looked in
the mirror and said I know that
something's not right and I'm skating
over it I'm kind of you know
sidestepping it I'm crossing my fingers
I'm oh maybe it's just withdrawing
contact if there's some difficult
situation you see between a parent and
child or anyone so I think we all have
that responsibility but I think it's
kind of erupting in our consciousness
through that very distant event that's
easier to talk about for a lot of people
yeah what do you make of this whole
situation I mean we're watching it seems
like the entire industry is collapsing
in front of us I know you're not a major
fan of what Hollywood has been putting
out in the type of moral preaching and
these people do and I'm not either
you're my moral preaching from Good beep
people do so the I you I would assume at
some level you're enjoying watching it
be exposed but we briefly for a second
before we started taping we're talking
about how this now could wring its
tentacles everywhere where everyone is
going to look back and go 20 years ago
someone touch my knee me too you know
like that and I don't want to really
focus on that part but we just don't
we're sort of opening a Pandora's box
here that yeah that is kind of dangerous
but I think it's essential yeah I mean I
I think this has to be done and this
yeah I'm glad them to be clear I'm glad
the monsters are going down well but who
knows who's who knows who's a monster at
the moment right now it's dark there are
lots of eyes out there there are
tentacles flying around like I don't
know who's a good guy and who's if I'm
you Kate clearly there's some people
like the Weinsteins and so on it's like
you know that's some pretty nasty stuff
and I know he's got a bunch of
investigations into rape but I think in
New York there's no statute of
limitations so they can go after that
but right now I think we kind of in the
midst of a hysteria and and that is
fairly common when these kinds of new
things come out so when I was a kid this
was child abuse oh sorry this was a wife
abuse wife abuse was the big thing that
was going on you know this was not
talked about you kind of I had a
feminist advocate Aaron Pitts see on the
show a couple years ago and she was
saying that she ran one of the first
shelters for women who were being abused
and a lot of times the priest would come
down and say sorry love you got to go
back you made a vow and all of this so
this was when I was a kid this was the
big thing that was coming out and then
it was child abuse that came out a
little bit later now this kind of sexual
harassment stuff is something that it is
coming out and because it's kind of a
hysteria it means you know there are
some bad people who are being exposed
there are people who are kind of on the
line who are going to take some real
hits to their reputations and of course
inevitably there are gonna be some good
people who were taken down unjustly and
them you know what we need to do is have
a conversation about all of this as a
whole you know where there is this power
disparity whether it's a sexual
exploitation and I I do believe and I
made this case before that that there is
a very very dark heart somewhere in in
Hollywood you know the stuff that Corey
Feldman has talked about the stuff that
Elijah Wood talked about
that the pedophilia and and all of this
there is some very very dark stuff in
there and the what do you think the
genesis of that is do you think it's
just power and money and then crazy
morals lack of morals I mean what is it
about Hollywood although this could be
happening in any industry well we just
happened to know that we've you know
we're hearing about it in in the sports
world um we've heard about it in
academia I just did a show recently on
how prevalent this kind of abuse can be
in government schools it is I think it's
just something that needs to come out
where it comes from in particular you
know power corrupts and when you have a
lot of power when you have huge numbers
of people who want the opportunities
that you offer them it's really tempting
and I think easy to use that power I
mean as a public figure I'm sure you're
aware of the effect that you have on
people I'm aware of the effect that I
have on people and it is very very
important to be aware of our everybody's
fundamental capacity to be corrupted by
power and if you have influence in the
world you need to be very very careful
about how you wield it but there is a
kind of a gross sort of sensuality in
certain areas of Hollywood that does not
appear to have any particular moral
restraint and you know I'm not religious
myself but it is a godless in Hollywood
and I don't know that they have the kind
of abstract ethics that would cause that
restraint or that that cognizance you
know the one great thing about
Christianity is how it talks about the
devil and temptations and fallen
humanity that puts you on guard against
your worst self and if you're not on
guard against your worst self and you
have that kind of power I think it's a
real slippery slope it's interesting you
just ended that with that about atheism
in Christianity because I've noticed
lately and I'm around obviously a lot of
atheists and I've talked to a lot of
atheists and believers and half
believers and non-believers and whatever
it is but I do sense a little bit in the
Atheist community that there's because
secularism has gone so arise suddenly or
whatever not secularism as much as just
our systems seem to be struggling right
now that I do sense that people have a
little more respect for certain pieces
of religion a little bit does that
makes sense I would certainly be the
poster boy for that for what it's worth
I was very harsh on Christianity earlier
in my career and I have apologized for
that and I have withdrawn from that
position because the one thing that
atheists I mean intellectually that the
position of atheism is very hard to
assail it because you have to go with
faith and if you have an empirical
rational view of the universe faith
doesn't cut it
faith is you know I'm right it's just
closing your eyes and saying that you're
seeing something different it's not the
same as being scientific so
intellectually atheism is a very very
easy position but the great challenge I
think that has happened you know seeing
how the rise of atheism is for it's
causing also a rise in state power it is
causing a decay in borders and
boundaries and nation-states it is
causing a moral collapse across society
it is causing a blurring of rational
biological categories and empirical
methodologies so I think that the big
concern I have is something like this
that the world is a difficult and
dangerous place and we need in the world
within our own hearts in the world that
is out there we need ways to guide
ourselves we need ethics we need
morality mm-hmm now atheists looked at
the religion looked at religion and said
not true and again metaphysically
epistemologically it's really hard to
sustain the argument for religion but
why did people believe in God did they
believe in God because they genuinely
believed that loves could be turned into
fishes and water could be turned into
wine and people could walk on water I
would say no I mean people didn't
believe if that that was a way that they
expressed why they found it so important
but it's miraculous but I think that
they believed in religion because it
gave a structure of self-restraint that
is essential for civilization and we can
talk about this with the book that you
need to restrain your own capacity and
for for violence and dominance and
aggression and bullying in order to have
rational discussions so people took
shelter in the church and the atheist
came along and they said that church is
terrible that church is is not a valid
structure and they ripped the roof off
the church but it's hailing and there's
lightning and people are then exposed to
the elements above
okay rip the roof off the church but you
better build another structure for
people to get to right so that's the
missing piece that's the missing piece
and this is why the for one of the first
things I did as a public intellectual
was work on a rational system of ethics
because we need to have a reason to have
self-restraint if we don't have a reason
to have self-restraint you know our like
our inner apes come out and it just
becomes about power and control it's
interesting because I had a really great
discussion on this with Michael Shermer
and with Dennis Prager and Michael is a
theist and a skeptic and he and
basically Dennis said that on the micro
level he's like yeah you can be moral I
have no doubt that you're more you know
looking at him in the face I have no
doubt that your moral and all of those
things but on the macro level for
society and that's really what you're
talking about that there isn't enough of
a structure otherwise I think there's an
interesting argument there for sure well
to me atheist ethics is like it's like
diets for thin people yeah I mean if you
already thin well I guess you would say
it's enlightenment values well okay but
they can say enlightenment values but
the reason we need ethics are for people
who really want to do evil you don't
mean I I'm a nice guy we're not sitting
there going okay there's a homeless guy
there's a cinder block I could go drop
the cinder block that we don't have
those impulses so for me I don't have to
fight this demonic lust for you know
what but there are people out there who
really want that and the fear of the
devil and the fear of Hell and the fear
of eternal damnation kept those people
in check it was like a little prison
that they could walk around inside if
they could rattle the cages and so on
but it it kept them restrained right
it's sort of a depressing view of what
humanity is in a way it's like that some
people could escape it yeah some people
just need it yes is sort of and I guess
that you could eventually get out of it
would be the hope if that's what it is
right well the data seems to be pretty
clear that if you're raised peacefully
as a child raised reasonably as a child
not here - not screamed at not yelled
not neglected then you're gonna grow up
to be a good person with empathy and so
on but you know like I said a couple of
percentage points out there are people
who had genuine sociopaths and
Psychopaths no conscience no remorse
Wilda power stuff what is going to
restrain them well in the past there was
the devil there was hell there was and
there was condemnation and ostracism
the community based on universally held
moral values the atheist came along and
okay undoing God is one thing and doing
ethics is quite another and if atheists
say well you know but we're good it's
like not all atheists not all atheists
are good and when people give up on God
and then they give up on morality as a
result I think what we end up missing is
not God but morality and and if we don't
have that need for self-restraint if we
don't have an understanding of the daka
side of human nature which we all carry
which we're all susceptible to the
atheists have a very optimistic view
that if you remove superstition from
people's lives paradise and I don't see
that particularly playing out right I
guess this is where Jordan Peterson who
you've had under show several times and
I've had on a bunch of times we talk
about these archetypes that we just need
them yeah but it's so interesting
because you yourself are an atheist and
in a way anyone listening to that five
minutes that we just did would go this
guy doesn't sound like much of an
atheist but I get you're making the
separation between your own intellect
and society I think it's a it's a really
rich spot well I mean I this is just a
question which you know people who are
watching and listening to this Dave can
just go to the worst person they know
and try and merely reason them into
being a good person no it is it is a
tough row to hoe like I do a call-in
show every week you house and hours of
talking with people about philosophy and
virtue and how to improve their lives
and so on and it's hard you know people
go and and try and talk other people
into being good and it's really really
tough on the other hand if you are
religious and it's you know Hellfire
damnation that's gonna get people's
attention now you have in a sense you
have heaven to offer them and you have
held to punish them with now for us as a
society you don't I don't think you
actually need heaven and hell but you
need rewards and punishments and jail is
not enough so the rewards and Punishment
that normally occur within society are
acceptance and ostracism you know there
there been studies that that show that
if you are ostracized by a community it
evokes the same mental and emotional and
physical states as direct physical
torture and then for obvious biological
we needed the cooperation of the tribe
to reproduce to survive to flourish but
we don't have the cuz we've got this big
giant redistributionist welfare state we
don't have the capacity to ostracize
anyone anymore people you know that
there used to be this very tight control
of her teenage sexuality in the past and
there was chaperones and and you know
the the shotgun weddings and so on right
right maybe a little too far in some
ways but why did people care so much
about youthful sexuality why was there
no sex before marriage and so on because
if your daughter got pregnant and there
was no one around to be her husband and
take care of her you as the parents
would have to pay to raise that child
she'd move in with you and then your
whole retirement plans would get
scotched and there wouldn't be any
playing bacharach on their southern
Riviera of France or something and so
you had a direct impulse but now there's
this big welfare state yeah you know
it's not that great but it doesn't
directly impact me so we've lost the
capacity to ostracize people and if you
don't have hell and you don't have
ostracism what the hell causes people to
restrain their bad behavior I don't have
an answer maybe there is one you know
the audience want to let us know I'd
love to hear it but I haven't seen one
yet well it's interesting because also
the welfare state in many ways it
benefits you to have more children which
is which is a whole other thing but
let's what let's circle back a little
bit just to the family know it's growing
you in but just to sort of end the
family thing yeah because we did a very
circuitous route to the to the end of it
so I think partly what people would say
and this is I was trying to find okay
what are people criticizing stefana
they say well what he's basically then
offering a cult that if you were to
disband this thing about the family even
if I think they you had legitimate
reasons no the alternative is it sort of
like come to me and join my cult I don't
hear you saying that I'm just joined by
cult
yeah yeah but that's that is sort of
like well if you if your goal to mately
the family is crumbling then what's
going to be on the other side of it I
think well I don't think I would say
that the family is crumbling at all my
concern is the next generation
if you had an abusive parents and then
you yourself become a parent and you
haven't resolved things with your
abusive parent and the abuse is most
likely going to be to some degree at
least transmitted down the chain so my
concern is the next generation that you
need to have a positive peaceful and
rational environment to raise your
children in and so that's my particular
concern you know regarding the cult
thing I mean okay so are people saying
that the family you can't leave you know
that's a little called neat that seems
okay okay you can't believe it's like a
roach motel and you check in
biologically through no choice of your
own but you can't ever get out no matter
how you treat it but let me ask you what
do you think would be behavior on the
part of a parent that may potentially
justify an adult's breaking relations
with them well if it was an endlessly
violent you know physically violent or
emotionally violent abusive relationship
I I agree with you once you're an adult
you have every right to manage your
relationships as you see fit and if your
parents either one of them or your uncle
or your brother or whatever it was was
abusive to you your whole life if you
don't feel if you yeah it would be nice
if you can sit down hopefully and try to
talk some of this out which is what you
said earlier but whether you do that or
not if you it's your choice I do believe
in the individual so I wouldn't I don't
operate on guilt so I wouldn't try to
guilt someone into not doing it and I
say that is someone that believes that
the bonds of family are incredibly
powerful perhaps the most powerful force
outside of us so the other thing too is
that to take a somewhat silly but I
think important analogy the post office
not very efficient you know way that the
Department of Motor Vehicles you know
there's that sloth scene in in Zootopia
yeah it's like it's not an accident that
that's a government place of employment
right and the reason why these you know
government schools and the in the IRS
and like these big giant government
institutions the government itself not
particularly responsive because you have
no choice now if you were to privatize
the post office and this sounds like a
political argument but it's not if you
were to privatize the post office then
we would assume that much like FedEx and
and other places that the service would
improve because
you have a choice mm-hmm so the funny
thing is is that some people have said
that I am somehow doing something
negative to families but the
introduction of choice is what raises
quality and so if parents out there just
assume that their children will always
have to spend time with them will always
be there for them well show up for
birthdays will be around when they when
they get older no matter how badly they
treat them that's kind of like the post
office
there's no volunteers in a weird way
whereas if you introduce the idea of
voluntary relationships within the
family my goal is not to make the family
worse it's like saying well you're gonna
destroy the post office by privatizing
it's like no no but we're going to get
better by introducing the value of
choice into the post office and what I
want is you know like these these old
Soviet factories you know like under
Stalin you know the old saying you know
that they pretend to pay us and we
pretend to work and they just you know
put out these indifferent goods because
there was no volunteerism there was no
positive or negative consequences so
they didn't care but if parents out
there and I'm very happy that this idea
is out there the voluntary family
because what it does and I'm aware of it
myself my daughter when she grows up you
don't have to spend any time with me so
I better make her child that's so great
that she wants to and so the
privatization of the family which is the
removal of well it's just like physics
you have to spend time with your family
no matter what means that parents as a
service provider actually are operating
more in the free market actually
operating more in the realm of
volunteerism and to me everything we can
move from absolutes to volunteerism is
how relationships get improved so I do
want parents to sit there and say I can
tomorrow yell at my kids but I know they
don't have to see me when they get older
or so I mean again how do we restrain
ourselves through negative consequences
and if you can imagine like it's way
back in the day like up until the
sixties in Canada where I live to get
divorced you need an Act of Parliament
now I was always told that easy divorces
improve the quality of marriage because
parents are sorry because I'm because
husbands in general say well my wife
could leave me so I Oh better be better
right whereas if you if you have to stay
married the quality of how you treat
your spouse goes down
and so in a sense by privatizing
marriage by allowing for no-fault
divorce by allowing for reason I think
it's gone too far but nonetheless by
privatizing marriage by making it more
voluntary and making it something you
could stay in or get out of the quality
of marriages I think in general has
improved if you privatize the post
office it'll prove if you privatize the
family of origin I think it improves the
goal is not to make things worse the
goal is to make things better now that
can be tough for some people you know if
you try and privatize the post office
believe this is the worst thing ever
catastrophe disaster right I mean and I
hate the guy who's saying privatize the
post office but the family needs to
improve for society to improve and the
only way I know how to improve things is
to privatize them
[Music]
you
[Music]